arnon est un mordu de la mode italienne
sa dernière trouvaille une petite
boutique à rome donc aidé à trouver le
site sur internet
il commande en ligne et paix avec sa
carte de crédit
sauf que les semaines passent et les
souliers n'arrive pas il avise la
boutique qu'il veut annuler son achat et
d'en cas de transactions conclues sur
internet la plupart des provinces oblige
les commerçants à rembourser dans un
délai de 15 ou 30 jours
mais la boutique en italie ne veut rien
entendre
arnaud doit-il faire le deuil de ses
bons souliers et son argent non roues il
peut demander à l'émetteur de sa carte
de crédit de rembourser son achat
c'est ça la rétrofacturation dans la
plupart des provinces la loi donne 60
jours aux consommateurs pour faire cette
demande
c'est tout est en règle l'émetteur de la
carte de crédit remboursera arnaud le
fin mot de l'histoire pour vos achats en
ligne
si le commerçant ne remplit pas ses
obligations pensez à la rétrofacturation
[Musique]